hello and welcome to roller coaster kun
3ds this is a game that I vowed to play
a very long time ago and I have no idea
why but here I am starting a new stupid
series in which I started playing this
pretty damn bad game by this time I
think the tycoon as well as the
simulator name are pretty much spoiled
by all the bad games that have come out
recently and even frontier said that
they're calling planet coaster planet
coaster to avoid getting the bad
reputation that the name tycoon carries
with it and I think that entire audio
was kind of kicked off when this game
was released it just seemed like a
milking cow to get more money for a
almost bankrupt company I'll just
quickly show it off here but I won't
really go into detail there are enough
reviews already on why this game is so
bad apart from the fact that it's not
even that bad but just really expensive
for what it gives you we've got a arm oh
wait I don't know if you can tell the
quality is pretty bad on my camera I'm
sorry about that but now we've got a
cool coastal story which is pretty much
the scenario of this game you've got the
coaster creator up in the top right
corner where you can make your own
coasters because that's pretty much the
point of the game then we've got the
Pikes sandbox down here which is what
the name suggests really and some simple
game options which is nothing really and
the coasters story is sort of the
scenario thing let me not get that lens
flare so I'm actually I've played this
game a little bit I don't know why but I
finished some of these scenarios and
they're all right but so far i am still
busy with this is actually the next
scenario that i'm gonna play and this
should kind of show off why i think this
game is so bad the loading screen is
actually looking all right though
oh god there's just stuff that you have
to read that is half of this game you
can barely even tell it doesn't want to
focus on it but here's this this old
chap and he has a some stuff to say that
it's not even relevant for the scenario
itself which is just great and they're
going to talk a bit and have an awkward
conversation this happens in front of
every single scenario that you have to
do and then we get another loading
screen which is alright so far but it
gets worse basically we get a little
overview of the park now where we can
see the terrible things that we get with
this little scenario it's actually not
too bad looking but one of the things
that I really hate about this game is
that there's a limit to the amount of
scenery objects that you can use and for
instance this park actually already has
the maximum amount of scenery objects
you can't make any forests or any
beautiful scenery it's pretty much just
parts and rides and like the original
roller coaster tycoon games we do have
some things that we have to do here
we've got our dear friend who helps us
out with what we have to do I actually
don't know what where I check that out
again right it was here in there in the
bottom I mean the top screen why didn't
I not pay attention to that so basically
we've got stuff that we can't read
because my camera is way too bad to pick
it up but here's the basic goal of this
thing we have to create a mummy coaster
that's one of the three steps then it
has to have a certain excitement rating
and be built with a certain amount of
money so pretty much we get this entire
Park down here which is very redundant
because all you really need to do is
build one coaster and looking around at
the pike it's not too bad looking it's
kind of reminiscent of the roller
coaster in three or sort of scenarios as
much as you can tell with the terrible
lens flare and quality cut this is awful
but um here's the here's the thing
there's just a random path that ends in
the middle of nowhere and has some grass
around it so gee I wonder where I am
supposed to build that mummy coaster
that they're talking about and this is
this is one of the problems that I have
with the game it has that scenario mode
but it
and have these same goals that you would
have with the original game you don't
get as much creative input you just get
certain goals like built there's one
right and things like that and even if
the original ICT games had that you
would have to build at least nine
coasters and or many more at least and
have more freedom in what you want to do
here is just these guys have a story
that is unreal oven to what you have to
do in the park and then you just do
something and you're done and you go to
the next next scenario or whatever I
should call it and it's very unclear but
yeah we can actually build some coasters
in this game which is not too bad you
should be able to screen on that screen
the UI is pretty annoying though is it's
simple but it's it's still not too great
to navigate through so here's the mummy
shuffle coaster is based on horror
themed coaster based weight is is a
horror theme goes through based on the
classic wooden wall mouse so it's pretty
much in one Mouse that's a that's great
to know and you can just rotate the park
with the with the arrow pad and you can
zoom in with it as well which works
pretty nicely and you have the joystick
to move around and the controls are very
similar to the earlier games you just
have a lot less control over what you're
doing let's place that down here and
I'll write that that should do right
there we go next thing I kind of want to
do is I should put down yes again
because this is looking terrible and mmm
that looks alright I suppose I'm gonna
go into a track building because that's
probably what everybody is interested in
we're going to make a little we can only
go straight up like way too steep for
some reason I have no idea why and it's
close to you should have a certain
excitement rating I don't know what
gives this type and excitement rating
but um i'm just gonna do it in a wild
mouse fashion I suppose okay I I cannot
do that okay whenever um we're gonna go
either right okay go right there
and is this is going to be the worst one
knows you've ever seen this is a gentle
slope which is not too bad but the
coasters are looking very wonky at best
and not really it's just not really too
great to design coasters in this game
since most of them just end up looking
awful and we can only have gentle slopes
down that's a very good to know I should
keep this coaster under 4,000 when it
comes to the costs I don't know if I'll
be able to do it that way yep it's
already becoming way too expensive I
think how much money do I have to start
off with yeah let's make it a bit
shorter and we're gonna go here and hmm
standard well i was actually I suppose
over here I won't actually I didn't even
check what the exact excitement rating
is or how I should get it so I feel that
I won't even be able to get it on this
first try but whatever really mmm okay
that is has very bad please be able to
make this not like that all right I'm
already failing terribly my entire
reputation is getting destroyed over
here let's see this should make it right
mmm it's that a curve to the rider to
the left oh and there it goes it
actually does have nighttime which is
pretty alright and let's see challenge
completes okay that's one challenge I
don't know about the rest are I should
test it if I'm gonna do that how did I
test it again and it barely makes it but
um it's doing something it's not too bad
and you you do actually have the coaster
cam as well in this game you can check
it out like that but as you can see it's
just very unsmooth and awkward that said
I've criticized this game a lot but I'm
gonna have to be quite honest I actually
did have this game put into my 3ds quite
some time
and sometimes when I'm really bored it
is actually somewhat fun to try it and
do certain things but it's far from what
the original ICT games are it's missing
a lot of things of that of those games
and most importantly it feels like it's
missing some sort of saw it's just a
empty husk of a game really you can play
it out of boredom every once in a while
so it's almost like a mobile game but
you can never really get long sessions
in it it's just not good enough for that
now to see if I can I don't think I
actually made it [ __ ] it doesn't have an
excitement rating of 2 or higher well
then I [ __ ] up I'm gonna have to at
least finish this thing or so I would
say it's not turning up on the on the
bottom screen that it's hard to actually
click it mmm see how do I build it again
all right there we go and now I guess
the best way to get more excitement in
there because this thing is just just
curves and [ __ ] like that is add more
curves I don't know what else could
really work here and you're gonna go
down there oh that's not going to work
right then you're going to go down here
and there and not do that you can have
that curve and now it should be good
come on you can do it let's actually get
on it again because I can't get used to
how terrible that looks actually when
you're testing it and you want to ride
it it automatically resets you can't
write it from a certain point even if
you wait for it to make the lift Hill
and then get on the coaster cam to see
what it looks like it just goes right
back to the start for some reason I have
no idea why but it's pretty annoying
sometimes when you want to check out a
certain part of the ride also the curves
absolutely kill you these things are not
smooth whatsoever but yeah I should
actually check these settings of this
thing I mean what it's like it's gonna
make citement of 0.6 okay I'm gonna
actually how to
you I'm actually going to have to
practice a lot more with this game
because I completely suck or so it seems
it's any reason why the excitement is
that low hmm I wouldn't figure the
intensity is actually very low as well
you know what actually let me mess
around with the thing see of these stats
are even any realistic at all and click
the coaster which is nearly impossible
to do thank you and edits let's see
here's the thing i'm going to want to
make a very dangerous contraption right
here we're going to go have this groove
and you can go down because that's
that's what what Moses do is what
they're like and I don't think I can oh
I can't do that thank you and then we're
going to have loads of curves see if
that makes the excitement better I don't
think it should but it it probably will
actually know a bit of air time very
extreme air time should probably help us
well so this is the most lethal bunny
hope you've ever seen and can add
another one of those because these are
this game likes to be very unrealistic
and there we go let's test it this time
around and get on the ride because it
looks beautiful okay I should probably I
should probably get this a bit closer
because you should be able to appreciate
how beautiful this coaster cam is how
very smooth it moves around I don't even
think I can bank the curves this is this
is really all i could do those were the
yeah the very lethal bunny hops by the
way we're just suddenly looked at the
sky for a second um okay so what's it
like now yep got a higher excitement
rating but it's still not enough and i
dropped my thing all right one one last
try I'm gonna have to at least finish
this otherwise i'll be looking like a
complete and utter idiot I mean I'm
gonna finish this game some point in the
future I am very much tempted to do so
no don't delete just edit it let's see
right so in order to make this thing
more exciting I suppose I'm just going
to make it higher go really fast because
apparently that's what this game wants
me to do um that should still have a
chain rights yep that's just the chin so
actually let me get back no that should
be fine go down and here comes my
masterpiece this is the oh right i can
actually that should help wow I feel
like an idiot for forgetting about that
oh there we go and bunny hop okay no
bunny hop and small curve got an
advisory alerts whatever that it's gonna
say I do some small stuff over here and
i think i can head back at this point it
should be a little bit more exciting at
least now but uh let's see anyway oh
yeah now it's got 1.5 even though it's a
it's a right that would give you a
whiplash in real life and is probably
actually deadly my excitement rating is
pretty damn high at least I'm getting
though at least it's not it's not all
that bad let's see I will hmm it seems
that it does like the steep hills a
little bit more so let's add more of
that and then at the end at some curves
I don't know if I'm actually still
within the price range that was supposed
to be but this is my final answer a
[ __ ] hell man 1.7 this time around I
think I'm gonna know I can't give up I'm
gonna have to finish this thing and I i
I'm god damn it I'm very sorry about the
struggle that this thing is at the
moment but that's pretty much what it's
like to play this game I wish it were a
little bit better can I even I should be
able to change the color scheme right
this is a very awful default color
scheme to be starting off with for a a
wild mouse type coaster I also wonder
what a mummy is doing in an otherwise
completely green park that does not have
even a scratch of Egyptian theme in it
and let's go down right there this is
turning into an out-and-back woody
that's terrible and we should almost be
there some little bunny hills at the end
this is way more expensive than it was
supposed to be but here's the thing too
I think but I'm not sure I can still
make it with this one okay the
excitement is actually lower because
it's too intense you know what I'm gonna
give up I this is pretty much more like
Oh second three and this is a low
quality video probably even a lower
quality game I hope you've enjoyed it
whoops had what you were looking for
probably not and I won't continue this
series actually no I will probably
continue this series but just look at pc
games which is better because i don't
have a capture card and well this 3ds
thing is just not working out in the
meantime I'll play this game in private
and see how well it goes hopefully a
little bit better than this one but in
any case thanks for watching our haps
actually I play some other simulation
games in the near future that should
indeed be a lot better than this one but
thanks for watching anyway